Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center every person who
prays in this Masjid every child that
memorized the Quran you will inshallah
share in that reward donate now guys and
do not delay
Ed your brothers and sisters and dear
friends
our dear brother zeeshan is away in
Pakistan so we are hosting the great
honorable gentleman in our beloved house
so basically today's video
um is I was actually looking at some
domestic abuse statistics I thought
there's anything on YouTube the Jordan
please talk about anything and I came
across this video of Jeremy Kyle
is a lot of facts
um so yeah so I came across this video
um which should we watch it yeah let's
watch it and I felt like she called the
shots in this relationship she locked me
in flat one there she slapped me in the
flat obviously me being angry I didn't
know that was locked I've gone over I've
grabbed the door handle pulled it and
it's come straight off in my hands so it
was stuck on a three-star about a three
Starry flat and I've had to jump off a
three-story balcony
my legs still not and I ended up in
hospital you know because she won't let
me out it's not funny though can I tell
you why it's not funny I don't want to
upset any of the audience because I
completely appreciate the fact that
you're here but I'll tell you why I
don't think you should laugh if this was
the other way around and a woman was sat
here and a bloke had locked her in a
flat and she had a jump out and injured
herself you lot would not be laughing
you would be saying he's a complete
nightmare he should be locked up and
that's disgraceful but somehow if it
happens to a blow that's funny that's
not funny is it what was your take on it
because I I take two things from it but
the audience reaction his story being
locked up in the third story floor
actually that's a group of Kyle here
because what he was saying is that if it
was the other way around
but look I mean there are some things
which if there was the other way around
it's it's not equal but generally
General is coming out from almost a
feminist perspective if you think about
it the the assumption is that both of
them are equal okay that a man and a
woman are equal and so whatever one does
to the other
the other can do to one but the truth is
I would say this like you know in terms
of domestic abuse a man has an advantage
yeah okay and that's that is clear no
one can say a man does not have an
advantage and so to try and pretend as
if a woman hitting a man is the same as
a man hitting a woman in most cases it's
not and just like I would say a man or a
woman claiming that a man hit a woman
you see so in other words a woman can
fake a claim or that a woman can she's
more likely according to statistics you
know to to make a claim uh that a man
done certain things assault her in a
certain way it could be even a sexual
way and then retract that later on like
for example Warren Faron has in his book
uh the myth of male power the original
book at the end of his book he had like
a something like a pilot study of woman
who had said that they had faced some
you know sexual assaults I mean and then
admitted later on that that wasn't the
case that they were doing it as as a
measure of spite so what it is is that I
feel we need to be fair uh I'll give you
another statistic because it was just
which is kind of unequal as well in
relation to the genders and I think I
saw this uh it could be the nspcc but I
could be mistaken
the the pro that the likelihood of a
woman assaulting a child is is greater
than a man I'm not saying it's because
of whatever reason it's just probably
because the woman has more time spent
with the child now what we're saying is
not everything is equal
we should be looking as much and I say
this clearly yeah we should be looking
as much or even more so yeah and the
amount of domestic abuse and when we say
that we're talking about legitimate
cases yeah that a man does to a woman
as we do with a child and the woman
because think about it I mean from a
psychological perspective if if the
child is being hit by his mother his
mother is teaching him how to beat up
other women
because a child that's being attacked by
a woman that woman now she's being she's
teaching the child if if you have a you
know a conflict with your wife or with
your partner deal with it in this way
get physical so in other words violence
is not the exclusive property of a man
neither is malevolent deception which
can which which can really harm somebody
however the the permutations of that
um are different between man and woman
and so the analysis is not okay is the
domestic abuse or domestic violence
between a man the same as a woman no a
man has an advantage in most cases if a
man puts his hand on a woman it's not
the same as a woman putting a hand on a
man a man is more likely to be able to
defend himself from a woman than a woman
be able to defend himself I mean think
about it it's very difficult for us to
sometimes as men to appreciate this but
a woman who's vulnerable and she has a
much bigger and stronger man who could
potentially kill her in her house with
her like a dangerous dog almost yeah I
mean that's a very scary Prospect but an
angry woman who has a child in the house
and we've seen videos of this online
where you know women grabbing a baby and
smashing its head and killing it true
crime stories and all these kind of
things is equally as problematic so we
need to look at this matter of domestic
violence in a completely different way
so I disagree with the premise which uh
Kai is is implicit in Kyle's thing which
is that actually if it was a bloke the
other way it's not the same though it's
true but do you think he was making that
premise or was he calling out the double
stones of the feminists by saying okay
you guys are laughing but what if this
was a woman saying my husband locked me
up in the third floor is violent towards
me and I was thinking of jumping off the
third floor would you guys be laughing
so if he's making a prince I agree with
you we can't because at the end of the
day they're not the same and we notice
if we look at America for example men's
shelters if I'm not mistaken there are
only two in Hall of America and there is
tens if not hundreds for women shelters
which I will not denying yeah because
it's kind of I'm not gonna say supply
and demand but if a woman have been
abuse of course there's no more shelter
however if we look at statistics as well
which Jordan Peterson talks about women
are as violence men yeah but they're
they're not they're not able to afflict
as much violence as well the only
difference is that men can use leave for
force and this is what we see when it
comes to Suicide women also commit
suicide or men tend to kill themselves
so we see the disparity there and also
for example if I was to I'm going to
give myself an example if I'm not going
to give you the example either imagine
somebody goes down the train station and
takes the top off yeah I've already done
that
but this part if imagine you take out
your private parts yeah it'll be
outraged but a woman could be easy just
go and Flash her breasts and everyone
the last is coming back just celebrate
it just imagine if a man did that so the
the the confusion here is that number
two the fact that the audience laughed
about it it shows me the issue of the
gender differences yeah they build
within us why do they find they need to
laugh I mean would you love if it was no
it shows you that innately you know the
differences and to see a man in such a
weak position being locked up by his
girlfriend is a laughable matter so that
shows us The Bitter truth behind us of
course is what that we innate no matter
how much we try to say gender is social
construct it's not it is something that
we are born with and in many different
instances like I said before and we'll
say again if a woman is walking down the
road and imagine I'm walking down the
road with my wife and a man puts an
iPhone and I run away I mean how's she
going to feel she's going to feel
vulnerable violated
anyone else come and say no that's his
right every feminist will be like how
they they would stick you on that guy
yeah I think you make a good point and
that's that's where the issue lies
because for example uh if a woman put
her hand on a man yeah and she harmed
him yeah and and this man now is he's
not responding because he knows if he
responds there's going to be Major
League ramifications yeah exactly now
she can she can use a weapon she can get
really physical and get Harmony and
stuff like that you know I'm trying to
say so let's say she does that is the
law going to see this case as it would
see the other the opposite it wouldn't
see it like the opposite even though
let's say for example the man didn't do
anything here yeah so what I'm saying is
that there's clearly a double standard
that's going on well there's two there's
two kinds of claims we need to be able
to differentiate number one
it's not the same with a man for the
most part puts his hands on a woman why
because it's true that he's stronger
than the woman and by doing so when he
puts his hand on her in a vicious way in
a way to harm her uh
you know harmful thing which our
religion has made a very clear
categorical
um you know this allowance of
prohibition of you know at the professor
clearly said that you know the dhar
Mubarak has not allowed and so on which
is the the the harmful and uh hitting of
a woman
um and also you know there's another
Hadith actually quite interestingly says
that the worst of you are the ones who
hit okay you know the ones the ones
worse of you are the ones who are here
but if what if a woman
in common now you can defend yourself of
course
a weak man trying to punch a bigger guy
no I get it I get it and even you know
the eye and the Quran
you know this if someone tried to do
anything more than let's say the
symbolic gesturing in this country and
even if they did this involving
gesturing they're putting themselves in
a position of weakness because if the
woman is scorned for and she spiteful
she'll go to the police and maybe
fabricate a story we're seeing more and
more of these cases happen and that's
why I was saying that the main issue in
these countries is false reports that
woman comes out and says this has
happened to me and not that's not
happened to her or that she started the
um of the violence herself or that she
claims that sexual assault has happened
to her and she's using that as a weapon
these are the issues and because the
justice system is not built on a high
evidentiary bar like in Islam where you
need Witnesses and all those kind of
things women can women can weaponize uh
accusation they are and so the way this
is this whole thing has been formulated
in this country has been it's been
horrible it's been absolutely it's one
of the worst history I've ever seen you
know how a woman can can accuse a minor
source is horrible and that's why they
gave birth to the red pill movement
which we are against also but I just
shows you you know where there's an
action there's a reaction yeah exactly
and I think that's it we're going to be
talking more about these gender roles
and stuff brother and sisters this was
just our take on this matter tell me
what you guys think and if the Muslims
are watching look what like we do these
videos to help the family room as well
understand your power towards like if
you're married as well you look as a
woman a Muslim woman it's your
femininity I'll be honest with you and
as a man it's your masculinity but it
depends what you what you define as
masculinity we're not talking about you
know becoming violent but
just find your true power within
yourself don't try to be the opposite
gender which we're seeing today that's
it for me the job until next time
is establishing a Masjid and a community
center if you don't need to build this
Mission Allah build a house for you in
Jannah with bricks of gold and silver
every person who prays in this Masjid
every child that memorized the Quran you
will inshallah share in that reward
donate it now guys and do not delay